JENNY BROWN: Uploading
and downloading
is all fine and good,
but sometimes you
need to do more maintenance
on the data in your buckets.
Today on Cloud
Storage Bytes, we're
going to dig into
Object Management.
So stick around.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
No matter how you get your
data into Google Cloud Storage,
once it's there, it's
manageable, meaning easy
to manage.
Just how easy?
Easy as one, two, three.
Let's talk about lists.
You see what I did there?
Anytime you want to do
something with the objects
in your bucket, it helps
to know what's there.
Starting with a list will get
you the inventory you need
of all of those 11,723
data objects you've got.
But if you've somehow
got that memorized,
feel free to skip ahead.
As we talked about
when getting data in,
there are two main
options for interacting
with your cloud storage, command
line gsutil and the Cloud
console.
Spoiler alert, this is going
to be true for a while.
So listing the contents
of bucket with gsutil,
you'll get a nice
structured response,
making it easy to see
what you've got and where.
And of course, the
Cloud console offers
a convenient visual interface
with dropdowns and buttons
for looking at all of your
files and directories.
So now that we know
what's in your bucket,
let's talk changes.
Rename an object with
a few specific steps.
Copy the object, making
another instance of it,
either in the current bucket
or in any other bucket.
Move the object
into a new bucket.
And for a more
permanent change, you
can always delete an object,
removing it from the bucket
and, effectively, from
your cloud storage.
The command line
utility was designed
to be as easy to remember and
as easy to navigate as the Cloud
console.
So these commands might
even look familiar to you
if you're used to working
in the command terminal.
No matter how you work with
it, Google Cloud Storage
is going to give
you the flexibility
you need to create the perfect
solution for your needs.
Now, there's plenty
more that you
can do with your data
and Google Cloud Storage,
but that's for another episode.
Subscribe, give
us a like, and let
us know what features
of Cloud Storage you
want to learn more about.
Thanks for joining us for this
quick byte of Google Cloud
Storage.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]